well this is not the only country where
these debates or the reality of people
moving across borders without permission
is unfolding in Italy something very
similar is happening Italian
investigators recently stopped a human
smuggling operation one that brought
Islamic extremists into Europe they were
posing as asylum seekers so far nobody
seems to have accused the Italian police
of racism why is that Rajaraja is a firm
leader of the UK Independence Party you
Kemp and he joins us tonight I feel
great to see you so you watch the debate
over what's happening at our southern
border here in the United States does it
remind you of things you've seen in
Europe how'd you know four years ago
when the Mediterranean crisis broke I
said in the European Parliament we must
not let our compassion imperil our
civilization because Isis will use the
Mediterranean route to get their
operatives into Europe sure enough last
year we were warned by Interpol that up
to 50 jihadis had come from Tunisia into
Italy already and today this gang as
you've announced has been found it's
been busted and they've been bringing
jihadis in I mean what clearer lesson
can there be of the great self harm you
can do to your nation to your
civilization to the safety of your
citizens if you don't say that a message
that people cannot just illegally come
into your country and I I see what's
going on today down in Texas and I would
say to Americans just look at this news
story look at Isis you know preying on
the weakness of governments over borders
and that tells me that Trump is
absolutely right with everything he's
saying so what's so interesting is you
all have been having these debates for a
lot longer than we've had them in the
United States was really on Trump that
got this debate out in the open the
extent it has been it does seem like
that consensus in Europe is is changing
I read a story today about how even the
left in Europe is starting to think
maybe borders are important yeah I mean
we've reached a point where you know
amongst the general population over 70%
in most countries that people are saying
well hang on this is crazy and you vote
sucker it's not just
terrorism if you look at what's happened
in places like Sweden what's happened in
places like Germany where huge numbers
of people from a completely different
culture have settled in those cities
there's all sorts of other sexual crime
and problems that have come - so
overwhelmingly European citizens are
saying this madness has to stop and we
are seeing political change now we're
not seeing it from mrs. Merkel we're not
seeing it from president macron of
france but i think what you're gonna see
in May this year in elections to the
European Parliament is a massive shift
in terms of political direction
controlling borders is becoming
fashionable again in European politics
and can I say not before time yeah
that's for sure but we you know we can
learn that less and I hope we will Nigel
fryers thank you as always good to see
you